so i started doing this thing where i i
make these calls
and and people seem to be somewhat
excited that i uh
that i've called them or click on them
whether i'm on twitch or instagram or
wherever i am on a phone call
and i tell them who i am and they're
very excited and they go let's do
something
so you know i just in the moment just
come up
based on what they are and who they are
and where they are
you know and what i mean by what they
are like if they're a parent or they're
a wife or a husband or a
teacher or wherever they are we kind of
in the moment
come up with things for them to do so
last night i was doing it
and this is one where a lady told me a
girl
a lady a young woman told me
her mother her mother is uh
very gullible and the one thing that her
mother
did not want in life like what would
piss your mother off i said
and she said if i got a tattoo so i
called as a tattoo artist
listen to this so as soon as i hear i
love annoying people
maybe it's not good but this is you'll
hear this do you have an idea
of somebody you want to prank i do i
want to prank my mom and dad because
they love you like so i was like
what's actually going to make them upset
and i think the one thing is
um if i tell them i got a tattoo you got
a tattoo
okay and it was it was supposed to be on
my shoulder
i think that we don't have to send her a
picture it was supposed to be on my
shoulder
but the guy did it he went up a little
bit high so it's on my neck
okay okay and i can't cover it number
one
that's not even why i'm calling you i
end up using
a used needle oh my god she'll die
because she's so
like freaked out about the coronavirus
yeah she's right all right so she's got
me
okay here we go she's about to call her
now
there we go the whole thing is ringing
really upset yes i do
hello spencer hi mom
what's going on what's up and we're here
um i'm at jason's all right
i know i'm sorry i'm upset so don't be
mad but um
jason had we had been talking about it
but then the quarantine happened and
then things are reopening so
he took me to um get that tattoo
what yeah why are you calling me tell me
that
um because it was only supposed to be on
the back of my neck
and then the guy did it too high and
it's on
part of my like fire on my neck and i'm
not going to be able to cover it
is this like a joke no
you said you would never get one any
place where it would be seen at all like
always blow down your back or something
yeah but
like that's not really even why i'm
upset because
um the tattoo artist called me he's on
the other line and he said
to me that he um used the wrong
the wrong needle he used a needle from
his partner and
he hasn't he hasn't felt what
what he he said that his partner had it
felt good and that i should get tested
for coronavirus
but that i needed to quarantine first
the
guy is the guy is calling me let me
let me let me merge the call so that you
can and here i go can you talk to him
yeah okay hold on here here okay hello
hello who am i speaking to
this is this is spencer's mother i'm on
the film with spencer
well can i can i first of all i want to
say i'm i'm very concerned and i
apologize for the
a little bit of a mix-up but i have to
say that
what it is it's uh what i what i drew
and i've never done it before but it's a
branch it's a
it's a branch from uh like a weeping
willow
and the bird takes off and flies
into the sky toward
the three little dwarfs from uh
you know i'm not really interested in
what dinner didn't do we're actually
understanding let me finish
let me finish ma'am ma'am ma'am
please please miss miss
i don't know who you are but let me talk
we'll deal with the
other issues in a minute let me talk
about the artistry
that's horrible ma'am you can't
you can't judge my artwork without even
seeing it don't tell me it's horrible
i'm not the least bit interested in your
artwork i personally do not care for my
daughter who's an
attorney could be out walking around
with a tattoo which may have different
places where
it's not acceptable well where is a bird
leaving a branch flying
wait wait wait answer answer this
question where
is a bird leaving a branch flying toward
three dwarfs
not acceptable name me two places
well you're not you're not going to sell
me on that i i love my work i really do
i don't really give a crap about that
i'm telling you what about the needle
but let me talk about the artwork the
bird
tell me what you're gonna do about the
needle no can you imagine
can you imagine i stopped this was the
last thing before you stopped it you
just said
no no i always say no and and she won't
listen to me isn't that beautiful think
about that
a bird leaving a branch
going toward three of not seven dwarfs
three of the dwarves
she's not even asking what dwarves i've
chosen
this woman anyway let's continue she's
getting angrier and angrier
no no no let me talk about the word the
bird
well i'm worried about people thinking
this is a pigeon and not a sparrow
i want to make it clear that the bird
is having trouble breathing josef left
his needle
in my pack that's not the problem the
problem is
i am trying joseph
can't breathe and he left his needle in
my back but that's not the problem the
problem is
the pigeon the sparrow looks like a
pigeon priorities people
a sparrow she was upset because it was
too high off her neck
she left early i just need to finish the
bird i don't want people
to i don't want to um misrepresent
birds
[Music]
what is wrong with you i'm talking about
a covenant virus
and you're worried about a [ __ ] bird
first of all
it isn't an effing bird and that's the
problem the problem is
i want people to know specifically this
is my artwork
this is my life she is wearing my heart
on her neck my daughter and this is her
life
yes but what i'm saying is what you're
misunderstanding
is that it's not a pigeon it's a sparrow
or your tattoo
bird i'm sorry
what do you think is more important my
daughter's life or your attaching bird
i don't understand the question first of
all you keep referring as a bird
i want you please man i want to fix my
daughter
if you are not going to refer to it as a
sparrow then i i have said enough it is
a sparrow and the problem
is right now it looks like a bird i'm
trying to get her back
in to just do the details on the bird
so that it is an identifiable bird you
keep saying
bird like you don't care what kind of
bird it is and that is what is getting
me upset
she doesn't want me to talk to him
because i have nothing nice to say he's
crazy
sparrow is more important than my
daughter
i know why are we even talking spencer
we need to accept
to find about his um partner
dad is there any urgency to do anything
one way or another with this tattoo
right now
okay so now the father the father just
joined him
now thank god because this guy knows
birds
can you imagine i know that if i would
have got this call from you jackie i
would be freaked
i would be freaked can you imagine this
guy's wrong
why do you keep she thinks joseph my
partner
can't breathe we used his needle in the
middle of a pandemic
and me is such a [ __ ] idiot i'm so
concerned that
my uh sparrow looks like a pigeon let's
continue
yes if i don't if i don't if i let the
ink dry
under her skin i promise you people are
going to think it's a pigeon
and i have within the next 24 hours
to turn it into a sparrow and i want it
to be a sparrow
is that too much to ask i think whoever
the woman i'm talking to
is being very unreasonable
[Music]
no she doesn't have my name you would
you write down my name
and this is one second and this is where
i will give away
because i feel bad as a parent i feel
bad because i know if i would get this
call
for my dot for you jackie which we've
gotten some calls in the past that we'll
talk about
after this um i i empathize i usually
don't empathize with the people i prank
but when it's a parent
and it's their daughter i empathize so
this is the reveal ladies and gentlemen
this is the reveal listen they want my
name
m and this is my last name m-a-n-d-e-l
yeah that's ridiculous
it's me tally mandel can she see you
i'm not you're kidding me
put it in front of the camera so we can
see her hi
hi it's me
there's no tattoo there's no birds
so that's it maybe reveal but go to the
youtube i have both of those
last two i have the full video so you
could see them that they're real but
can you imagine they're having a serious
conversation i don't care what the
[ __ ] bird is why do you keep talking
about the bird
you said you used a used needle on my
daughter
forget about the needle ma'am this is
not a pigeon
can you imagine that's how i spend my
day every day